nous sommes heureux d'accueillir ce
matin madame jacqueline gourault
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales pour discuter du projet de
loi relatif à la différenciation la
décentralisation la déconcentration et
portant diverses mesures de
simplification de l'action publique
locale qui sera examiné par le sénat
dans les semaines prochaines
je rappelle que compte tenu de la
diversité des sujets abordés
quatre commissions vont se partager la
l'examen de ce texte la commission des
lois
je salue françoise gatel la commission
des affaires économiques
monsieur d'arnaud je te salue ainsi que
la commission des affaires sociales
bénéficient d'une délégation au fond
notre commission s'est quant à elle vu
déléguer au fond l'examen de quatre
articles articles 9 13 61 et 62
par ailleurs elle s'est saisie pour avis
de 25 articles ayant trait aux
transports l'aménagement du territoire à
la transition écologique et à la
biodiversité
madame la milice ce projet de loi qui a
été maintes fois repoussée focalise de
fortes attentes de la part des élus
locaux et suscite de nombreux
questionnements
le sénat travaille aujourd'hui depuis
plusieurs années sur la question de
l'efficacité de l'action publique dans
une démarche transpartisane en 2020 il a
publié 50 propositions pour le plein
exercice des libertés locales dans
lesquels il appelait au renforcement de
l'autonomie des collectivités locales et
de la différenciation territoriales dans
le respect du principe d'égalité
c'est dans le même esprit qui a été
lancée en février 2021 une consultation
à destination des élus locaux
il en ressort il en ressort des attentes
très fortes de la part des élus autour
de plusieurs axes j'en citerai deux
l'approfondissement de la
décentralisation et du principe de
subsidiarité afin de permettre un
exercice des compétences ou plus près
des réalités du terrain et le
renforcement des pouvoirs des
collectivités en matière de santé une
préoccupation singulière accentuée par
la crise sanitaire face à laquelle les
élus locaux se sont trouvés en première
ligne or fort
et de constater que ce texte répond que
partiellement aux préoccupations
s'agissant du volet décentralisation et
différenciation le conseil d'état lui
même note dans son avis que les
équilibres institutionnels ne sont pas
modifiées et que les mesures relatives
au levier d'action des collectivités
sont de portée modeste je constate que
de nombreux articles se borne à
clarifier des répartitions de
compétences comme l'article 5 qui
réaffirme les rôles respectifs de la
région du département et du bloc
communal en matière de transition
écologique sans que cela s'accompagne de
nouvelles attributions ni d'un véritable
renforcement des capacités d'action des
collectivités
avant de vous donner la parole d'un maïs
je souhaite vous interroger et plus
précisément sur deux points deux points
qui nous interpelle l'article 48 vise à
modifier l'organisation et les missions
du centre d'études et expertise sur les
risques l'environnement la mobilité
l'aménagement le serema afin de mieux de
mieux prendre en compte les chaînes
locales
j'adhère totalement à l'objectif de
tourner davantage c'est un spot cette
instance vers les collectivités locales
dans sa gouvernance et dans ses
finalités
cependant pourquoi avoir fait le choix
de renvoyer à une habilitation plutôt
que d'inscrire ces dispositions
directement dans la loi le serema est un
acteur clé des politiques publiques
locales et du déploiement des
innovations dans les territoires et à ce
titre l'article 48 me semble être une
clé de voûte de ce projet de loi je
regrette donc que le gouvernement ait
décidé de contourner le débat
parlementaire sur ce sujet ce
souhaiterais que vous nous en disent y
ait davantage sur les mesures sur les
mesures qui pourraient figurer dans
lordonnance comptez-vous prévoir une
représentation paritaire des
collectivités de l'état en son sein afin
que le cinéma deviennent véritablement
un outil partagé
comment allez-vous améliorer l'accès des
collectivités au service du cinéma en
particulier s'agissant de cette situés
dans les territoires les plus fragiles
je souhaite également vous interroger
sur un sujet sur lequel notre commission
a beaucoup travaillé ces dernières
années le sujet de la désertification
médicale
le projet de loi comporte assez peu de
dispositions sur ce sujet qui constitue
pourtant un enjeu
central de la territorialisation des
politiques publiques
l'article 31 vise à modifier la
gouvernance des ars afin de renforcer le
poids des élus au sein des conseils de
surveillance qui deviendrait par
ailleurs des conseils d'administration
cette évolution me semble aller dans le
bon sens mais pourquoi ne pas être allé
plus loin
le sénat a proposé à plusieurs reprises
ces dernières années de confier la
présidence drs à un élu local
par exemple le président du conseil
régional où un membre du collège des
collectivités territoriales de la rs
quel regard portez vous madame la
ministre sur ces propositions
je vous remercie encore de votre
présence et vos réponses sur ce dossier
important que nous allons examiner
rapidement mamie je vous laisse la
parole et oui c'est oui oui c'est le
rapporteur c'est le rapporteur toujours
madame la ministre madame la ministre je
rejoins les propos du président ce texte
cristallise de nombreuses attentes de la
part des élus mais également de la
population et de nombreux acteurs en
tant que rapporteur pour avis de ce
projet de loi je forme le voeu qu'il
permette de renforcer l'action des
collectivités locales en particulier
dans le domaine des transports et le de
la transition écologique et qu'il ne
constitue pas une simple déclaration
d'intention
je souhaite à mon tour vous interroger
sur plusieurs points les articles 6 et 7
prévoit le transfert des routes
nationales non concédées aux
départements et métropole ou régions
sous la forme d'une expérimentation
le dispositif proposé est à double
détente les départements et métropole
devront se prononcer sur l'opportunité
du transfert puis les régions
volontaires pourront bénéficier d'une
mise à disposition sous la forme d'une
expérimentation des routes dont les
départements et métropole ne rompt pas
du madame la ministre à travers ce
dispositif ne craignez-vous pas d'aller
vers une complexification de la gestion
du réseau routier
pensez vous que cette méthode de
répartition des compétences à la carte
permettent une gestion efficace des
routes nationales
s'agissant de l'expérimentation prévue
pour les régions il me semble que la
durée de cinq ans proposé par le projet
de loi est trop courte pour permettre
aux régions à la fois d'acquérir une
véritable expertise technique en matière
de gestion du réseau routier et
d'engager les dépenses d'investissement
que pensez vous de l'idée d'un
allongement de l'expérimentation à huit
ou dix ans enfin les compensations
financières suscite de vives inquiétudes
il est prévu que leur méthode de calcul
repose notamment sur les dépenses
d'investissement des cinq dernières
années
de fait les parties du réseau peu
entretenues feront donc l'objet de
faible compensation financière comment
l'état va-t-il aider les collectivités à
faire face aux besoins d'investissements
liés au transfert des routes
je souhaite également vous parler de
l'article 9 pour lequel notre commission
bénéficie d'une délégation au fond cet
article permet le transfert de petites
lignes ferroviaires d'intérêt régional
et des gares afférentes aux régions si
je salue ce dispositif qui élargit le
champ du transfert qui était prévu par
la loi je m'interroge sur un point
comment concilier la décentralisation de
ses lignes avec le maintien du niveau
d'exigence du réseau en termes de bon
fonctionnement et de sécurité des
régions auront la possibilité de confier
la gestion des infrastructures
transférés à des personnes privées
il convient d'éviter d'aller vers un
éclatement du réseau enfin je souhaite
vous poser une question plus générale
l'article 49 consacre au niveau
législatif le dispositif france services
dont le pilotage est assuré par l'
agence nationale de cohésion des
territoires
notre commission suit de près ces
problématiques elle avait d'ailleurs
examiné au fond la proposition de loi
portant création de cette agence en 2018
pouvez vous faire un point d'étape sur
le déploiement des espaces france
service l'objectif d'en ouvrir
deux mille cinq cent d'ici le 1er
janvier 2022 vous semble-t-il accessible
malgré le ralentissement casio n'est par
la crise sanitaire
mais la ministre
c'est à vous
merci beaucoup d'abord et salue à
nouveau monsieur le président salué les
rapporteurs et l'ensemble des sénateurs
et sénatrices ici présentes
vous avez rappelé monsieur le président
que le projet de loi relatif à la
différenciation a été maintes fois
reculer il n'a pas été maintes fois
reculé il a été il a duré assez
longtemps dans sa préparation puisque
nous avons fait une consultation sur
l'ensemble du territoire et que le coc
vide est arrivé où la cause vides selon
les écritures et que c'est vrai que ça a
mis du temps plus tôt après il ya eu une
interrogation pour être très exact sur
le fait que ce texte soit inscrit dans
le calendrier
c'est ça qui a été une vraie question
puisque il y avait un certain
embouteillage parlementaire mais
finalement ce texte a été inscrit et
j'ai bien entendu ce que vous avez dit
parfois et françoise gatel s'est déjà
exprimée de cette manière vous avez dit
qu'il n'allait pas toujours assez loin
soit je vous entends simplement j'assume
le fait que c'est un texte qu'il a fallu
préparer avec à peu près 20 ministres et
secrétaires d'état puisque c'est un
texte extrêmement transversale et que ça
a été un gros travail et qu'au fond il
ya un moment on s'est mis d'accord sur
des équilibres et ce texte est ce qu'il
est mais je crois qu'ils répondent au
fond à ce que j'avais entendu sur les
territoires je voudrais rappeler trois
points qui me semblait absolument
évident et que sur lequel je crois nous
sommes d'accord c'est une attente très
forte à l'égard de nos politiques
publiques de renforcement de proximité
ça je crois que c'est un point qui est
très important et quand je dis proximité
j'ai même l'audace si je puis dire de
dire proximité compte sept exercées par
des collectivités territoriales
de proximité mais aussi une attente
assez forte d'un état territoriale de
proximité
je crois que les deux choses sont très
importantes
le deuxième point qui nous semble
évident et qui est enfin dont nous avons
déjà discuté lors de débats
parlementaires
c'est l'aspiration tout aussi importante
à une meilleure prise en compte des
particularismes ou des particularités
locales et qu'il y ait une organisation
territoriale des politiques publiques -
unis ford moins rigide et qui s'adaptent
mieux aux territoires je crois que c'est
le deuxième point est le troisième point
c'est ce que je ressentais aussi
fortement sur les les discussions que
j'ai eues sur les territoires c'est que
les élus demandaient non pas comment
dire un changement fondamental de
l'organisation territoriale
il y avait une certaine fatigue à
l'égard des réformes institutionnelles
nombreuses et variées depuis 20 ans et
même depuis 10 ans si on même si on
augmente la dix ans il y en a eu
beaucoup
et qu'il y avait un besoin de stabilité
institutionnelle sur les territoires ce
qui n'empêche pas évidemment de faire
des modifications de progresser et de
répondre à des problèmes qui se posent
ici ou là mais j'assume tout à fait que
cette loi n'est pas un grand soir n'est
pas une modification institutionnelle je
dirais des collectivités territoriales
et donc à la demande du président nous
avons préparé cette loi pour qu'elle
soit un acte de décentralisation adaptés
à chaque territoire et résolument
tournée vers l'action publique et non
pas une redistribution des compétences
je suis très claire et j'assume tout à
fait l'orientation de cette loi je ne
reviens pas sur le fait que j'ai aussi
discuté beaucoup avec les associations
d'élus que je ne vous cite pas vous les
connaissez elles sont nombreuses et nous
avons eu beaucoup d'échangés une
continuons à voir des échanges encore
hier et puis bien sûr je voudrais dire
aussi que ce travail de préparation
s'est fait également avec vos
rapporteurs que sont mathieu darnaud et
et françoise gatel que j'ai rencontré le
président du sénat en tête à tête pour
parler de ce projet de loi et pour
m'assurer bien évidemment ce qu'il m'a
confirmé qu' il y avait une volonté du
sénat
de voir aboutir ce texte est
naturellement le président n'a pas
manqué de le rappeler ce que vous avez
rappelé vous même monsieur le président
le travail du sénat dans ce domaine
notamment de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales que préside
françoise gatel et les 50 propositions
qui ont été bien sûr étudié et il y en a
déjà un certain nombre qui sont dans le
texte
et certains autres pourraient y être
introduites bien sûr par amendement
après de nouvelles discussions que nous
pourrions avoir alors sur les mesures
dont vous êtes saisis au fond je
voudrais peut-être m'arrêter un peu plus
longuement que sur les autres articles
sur l'article 9 et sur les petites
lignes ferroviaires qui vient compléter
les dispositions de l'article 172 de la
loi l'homme qui permet le transfert aux
régions
en effet suite au travail mené
conjointement avec les régions et en
particulier cher daniel la nôtre qui a
été je dirais à ses précurseurs dans le
domaine il est apparu nécessaire de
préciser que le transfert concerne non
seulement la voie ferrée mais aussi les
gares et l'ensemble des installations de
service afférentes c'est à dire que ce
soit une décentralisation complète pour
être très précise et peut-être tout
repeint dire à l'ensemble des sénateurs
ici présents quand que dans les accords
que nous avons passé avec le grand est
où la région centre val de loire
il ya au fond trois séries de ligne il
ya les lignes qui sont exploitées par la
sncf
entièrement et cetera il y aura des
lignes de partage encore 2
partage le trafic entre les régions et
la sncf et les troisièmes lignes qui
sont complètement transféré à la sncf
je crois que c'est évidemment une mesure
importante pour nous pour le transport
bien évidemment et pour parfois faire
revivre des lignes qui avaient été
abandonnés par la sncf
et bien sûr il est très important aussi
que les gars soient réutilisés et c'est
important pour nos villes moyennes et
nos petites villes qui pourront aussi
éventuellement valoriser des fonciers
bien souvent au coeur de leur centre
ville pour leur donner une vraie
fonction dans un projet global
d'aménagement l'article 13 qui vise à
renforcer le rôle des régions en matière
de biodiversité
alors c'est vrai je réponds en même
temps est ce que jean françois g le
président vous avez dit vous avez dit
vous avez présenté sans oui on l'a fait
parce que ça n'était pas écrit nulle
part la responsabilité dans le domaine
de la biodiversité
c'était écrit nulle part donc nous
l'avons milan le texte pour que ça soit
je dirais dans le droit écrit et les
espaces natura 2000 concours à la
politique d'aménagement des
collectivités territoriales et vous
savez que ce sont de formidables
réservoir de biodiversité que nous
devons collectivement protéger et nous
décentralisons donc la gestion de ces
sites qui permettra de conduire une
politique de proximité dont je parlais
de tout à l'heure et de mieux les
intégrer par exemple dans les trames
vertes et bleues
cela permettra une véritable
clarification des compétences entre les
collectivités l'état la gestion des
sites étant aujourd'hui exercer dans les
faits sur 60% d'entre elles ou d'entre
eux puisque c'est les sites par les
collectivités
c'est une décentralisation qui est
particulièrement aboutie puisqu'elle
permet à la région de 10
osez du levier réglementaire du contrôle
des sites et du financement
elle laisse à l'état des missions de
coordination avec l'union européenne et
de nomination des sites peu de sites
nouveau d'ailleurs le réseau est déjà
particulièrement aboutie et l'évaluation
des incidences des projets sur les sites
natura du mai du fait de la technicité
et de l'expertisé nécessaire en
cohérence avec l'instruction d'un
certain nombre d'autorisations dépendant
légalement de l'état les zones maritimes
continueront de relever de l'état
nous transférons le terreau est pas le
maritime car s'agissant de domaine
public maritime
c'est une compétence exclusive de l'état
et pour des raisons de sécurité pour des
raisons de défense il n'a pas vocation à
être décentralisé l'article 61 prévoient
quant à lui le financement d'aménagement
d'autoroute concédée par des tiers dans
ce texte nous rendons possible qu'au
financement de la réalisation de battre
deux bretelles autoroutières de sorte à
améliorer leur accès à ces axes de
communication désormais un grand port
maritime une entreprise des aménageurs
pourront participer au financement
ce qui permettra d'accélérer la
réalisation des projets structurants
comme le projet du diffuseur autoroutier
du groupe du grand port du havre qui est
en plein dans ce projet je crois que
c'est quelque chose d'important que
d'ouvrir à la participation financière
qui permettra évidemment souvent à des
projets de se réaliser plus rapidement
et c'était une demande évidemment de
beaucoup de collectivités territoriales
enfin l'article 62 vise à clarifier les
procédures applicables lorsque des
arbres d'alignement
peut-être abattu ça peut paraître un
truc bizarre mais aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de contentieux
il y a une vie des difficultés quand il
y a un projet de tram ou et qu'il y a un
projet d'importance général et public
il y a une véritable confusion sur
l'autorité compétente pour procéder à
l'abattage de ces arbres
lorsqu'il est nécessaire à un projet
d'aménagement les arbres d'alignement
bénéficient d'une protection
particulière étant donné l'importance de
leur rôle écologique évidemment cette
mesure vise à clarifier les procédures à
suivre
il reviendra ainsi aux préfets de
délivrer les autorisations d'abattage et
de vérifier les mesures de compensation
mise en oeuvre cela sécurisera les
projets d'aménagement des collectivités
qui sont trop souvent retardée du fait
donc de contentieux issu des
incertitudes actuelles sur l'autorité en
charge de délivrer les autorisations
tout en assurant la protection de ces
arbres ta sujets dont pour débattre
longtemps quand on a été
on est nombreux avoir été maire dans
cette salle on sait combien c'est un
sujet difficile quand on veut toucher à
un arbre et que parfois ça dure des
années et que ça bloque des projets
d'aménagement voilà c'est un peu une
facilitation qui est donné si je puis
dire et de repos faire reposer ça sur le
préfet alors vous pourrez dire ça
pourrait être le maire il se trouve que
d'une manière générale je fais les
questions et les réponses
les élus sont plutôt contents de cet
article plutôt que d'avoir même la
charge du sujet dont voix
et ce projet de loi illustrera notre
volonté constante de poursuivre je
dirais les facilitations qu'il s'agisse
des collectivités ou des services de
l'état
bien évidemment je vais répondre aussi
aux questions que vous m'avez posée par
ailleurs sur le dispositif de
compensation des transferts de route ça
c'est le truc habituel bien évidemment
on sait tous que transfert qui dit
transfert 10 transferts de moyens c'est
inscrit dans la constitution et les
mesures proposées dans le projet de loi
reprennent pour l'essentiel les règles
de transferts de compétences en matière
financière et de porcelets et de
personnel depuis la loi de 2004 et la
loi de 2014 la loi matin en matière
financière on calcule la compensation
comme vous le savez sur cinq ans pour
l'investissement et sur trois ans pour
le fonctionnaire fonctionnement pardon
cela permet bien sûr un équilibre dans
les coûts et charges de ce dispositif et
ça préserve les intérêts normalement des
collectivités et de l'état
ce que on préserve aussi les intérêts de
l'état vous trouvez faut trouver un
équilibre dans tout cela
vous m'avez posé des questions aussi sur
français rif le déploiement de francs
services se poursuit bien on saura à
2000 à mon avis à en début 21 comme
c'était prévu
nous avons aujourd'hui de m'échanger pas
combien on en a aujourd'hui 3 pas le
chiffre exact me rappelle plus mais
enfin je crois qu'on en a plus de 1300
1300 aujourd'hui l'objectif c'est de
mettre des france service là où il y en
a besoin
alors quand le président de la
république avait lancé le projet il
avait dit une par canton bon alors
évidemment c'était pour montrer qu'il en
fallait partout en réalité on sait déjà
qu'il y en a des fois plusieurs par
canton parce qu'il ya des cantons qui
sont extrêmement étendue et que
naturellement c'est quand on enfin c est
france service
alors il ya deux vous savez il ya les
anciennes msa paix qui sont devenus des
francs service et puis il ya celles qui
sont créés ex nihilo et a les deux les
deux aspects mais tout ça c'est sous une
charte commune qui qui impose qu'ils
aient au moins neuf services et qui
engendre les financements bien sûr de
l'état il y à des mets sap et je le dis
parce que comme ça je vais jusqu'au bout
il ya des mais ça paie qui ne sont pas
tout à fait au niveau il y en a
certaines et notamment chez nous avons
des discussions avec la poste qui a
porté beaucoup de m et ça paie quand
manuel valls avait lancé ce programme et
la poste elle même choisi
de ne pas maintenir un certain nombre de
m échapper à certains endroits parce
qu'ils considèrent qu'ils ne sont pas
atteints capacité d'aller jusque à
l'exigence de la charte mais cela celles
ci seront remplacés bien sûr par
d'autres et je crois que nous
atteindrons effectivement
le chiffre que
qui avait été prévu je n'ai pas
d'inquiétude là-dessus alors ensuite
vous m'avez posé des questions sur si
j'ai bonne mémoire sur le sert et m'a
alors je rappelle quand même que l'
ordonnance et ça n'empêche pas le débat
parlementaire
quand même d'ailleurs tu vois on en
parle pourquoi on a fait ça par
ordonnance moi je sais pour garantir
parce que nous avons un besoin de
travailler avec le conseil d'état parce
que c'est un sujet extrêmement délicat
j'ai pas si vous vous rappelez déjà
j'avais essayé de le mettre
louis-jean doit doit s'en souvenir
quand nous avons débattu de la haine
c'est et j'avais déjà essayé de mettre
l'histoire du cinéma alors je vais vous
expliquer très simplement ce que ça veut
dire l'histoire du sein des serema pour
mettre dans la loi le serena est un
établissement public qui travaille
aujourd'hui à 80 % pour l'état et
seulement 20% pour les collectivités
territoriales
il ya à peu près 23 implantations en
france de serrer ma le siège du serena
est à bron près de lyon
l'objectif c'est d'ouvrir la capacité
aux collectivités territoriales
d'utiliser les services du serema sans
passer par les marchés publics
je vous le fais je vous le faites très
simplement et pour que au fond le sert
et mac est un outil avec des ingénieurs
route des ingénieurs hydrauliques des
intérieurs bâtiments soient mis à la
disposition des collectivités
territoriales d'abord je vais vous dire
avec la décentralisation et les
transferts de compétences qui ont eu
lieu et qui vont avoir lieu si on veut
que ce cet outil jeu dng neri
soit pérenne et eh bien il faut le faire
le faire vivre et évidemment nous avons
déjà une convention l' agence nationale
de cohésion du territoire avec le serema
pour faciliter dans toutes les
politiques publiques que nous faisons
l'accès aux serema mais en faisant ce
qu'on appelle alors ce que les juristes
appellent du in house
voilà l'objectif de cet article il n'y a
pas de loup il n'y a pas de loup mais on
veut le sécuriser à fond par un travail
avec le conseil d'état c'est pour ça que
nous l'avons fait par ordonnance
voilà voilà
[Musique]
la désertification médicale qui est un
sujet évidemment que nous connaissons
tous qui est un sujet difficile
un certain nombre en fin je crois que le
ce qu'avait fait agnès buzyn est
fondamental c'est à dire faire sauter le
le numerus clausus
mais évidemment on sait bien que le
numerus clausus le temps que cela
produise son effet s'il faut une
génération de nouveaux médecins
évidemment alors
il n'y a pas beaucoup de miracles dans
ce domaine mais le projet doit 4d
comporte plusieurs mesures pour
faciliter l'installation de personnel
soignant dans les territoires à
l'article 32
on permet le financement par les
collectivités locales des
investissements dans les établissements
de santé à l'article 33 et 34
on consolide la possibilité pour le
département et le bloc communal de créer
et gérer enfin de créer de recruter et
gérer des personnels de santé dans les
centres de santé
je crois que c'est quelque chose qui qui
est très important nous avons mis aussi
ses annexes mais le préfet de région à
la tête le côlon non c'est pas ça à la
tête des ars nous avons toujours la rs
mais nous faisons entrer davantage
d'élus dans le conseil d'administration
des ars alors je sais je sais à queue on
aurait peut-être enfin que certains
auraient aimé qu'on aille plus loin
c'est déjà une étape et à travail pourra
être encore fait mais c'est une étape
qui est importante et
le gouvernement a beaucoup travaillé sur
ce sujet le ministère de la santé aussi
qui défend bien sur ses fonctionnaires
c'est normal les ars
mais je crois à titre personnel que la
crise de l'aco vide à montrer évidemment
que personne ne pouvait imaginer et
aucun pays d'ailleurs n'a imaginé un as
a montré bien sûr qu'il était nécessaire
de faire évoluer les liens entre les ars
et les préfets notamment et notamment
nous ce n'est pas dans le texte mais
c'est quelque chose qui est qui est en
cours
c'est aussi d'avoir au niveau
départemental des représentants des ars
et qui nécessite que ce soit des gens
bien formés de qualité et qui travaille
en direct avec les collectivités
territoriales
je sais pas si j'ai je crois que j'ai
tout fait c'est bon bien merci même un
ami pour ses réponses
je dois avoir une quinzaine de demandes
de parole donc et on a une une audition
à 10h15
donc 15 demandes de parole si vous
prenez deux minutes et deux minutes de
réponse voyez on n'est pas loin d'être à
10h15 donc je vous demanderais d'aller
directement à la question et d'être bref
je vais donner la parole aux odeurs
rapporteur de la commission des lois
madame gatel et puis mathieu darnaud
merci beaucoup monsieur le président de
votre invitation bonjour madame la
ministre moi je veux d'abord vous
remercier de nous tombera la main avec
ce texte un peu traîné mais faites nous
confiance on va s'occuper du reste si je
puis dire en tout cas je salue et votre
ténacité sur un sujet qui est difficile
vous l'avez dit
je suppose des arbitrages
interministériels or le président l'a
rappelé j'essaierai d'être rapide
on est d'accord avec vous que les grands
soirs les big bang territoriaux les
collectivités en sorte on va surtout pas
recommencer la copie n'est pas parfaite
mais il ne serait tout aussi hasardeuse
et sans doute que la guérison
viendra-t-elle de souplesse accordée aux
collectivités pour s'organiser le mieux
possible selon la réalité la diversité
de leurs terrains et que en tout cas il
n'y a qu'un sujet que nous devons
partager c'est celui de l'efficacité de
l'action publique après on trouve les
moyens alors j'aurai trois points madame
line is le premier le président longeole
a dit je sais combien le sujet est
important pour les membres de cette
commission c'est l'accès aux soins est
ce qu'on appelle d'une manière très
triste les déserts médicaux alors vous
offrez c'est très bien la possibilité à
des à des collectivités de créer des
centres de soins il manque la deuxième
partie de de l'équation madame la
ministre est ce que cela veut dire que
les collectivités qui prendront ces
initiatives nécessaires auront en charge
le financement où il y aura-t-il des
répartitions avec l'état deuxième chose
ce sujet propose enfin le projet propose
à juste titre aussi des transferts de
personnel parce qu'on ne peut pas avoir
les compétences si on n'a pas les moyens
c'est vrai pour les établissements
sociaux c'est vrai aussi pour les autres
toutefois je voudrais attirer
l'attention sur la difficulté qu'on aura
puisque l'intention est là mais le
diable est dans les détails sur les
établissements sociaux je sais qu'il ya
une unanimité des syndicats contre cette
proposition mais quand on réfléchit à ce
qui est proposé
le directeur de vienne serait détaché
auprès du département me n'y aura que le
directeur ça veut dire que le directeur
a du reste personnelle resterait de la
fonction hospitalière alors est-ce que
cela va faciliter l'exercice de la
responsabilité du directeur moi je
j'en doute un peu et troisième point ce
sera le dernier sur la déconcentration
vous avez à juste titre rappelé madame
la mini c'est je partage totalement ce
que vous dites il ya nécessité de mettre
en oeuvre ce principe de subsidiarité
pour faire les choses au plus près du
besoin mais qu'on a besoin d'un état
fort dans les territoires la crise a
montré et surtout d'un d'un états unis
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui les élus
ont une succession d'interlocuteurs la
dréal enfin je vais pas les citer la dea
fip et chacun vit sa vie de manière
autonome à tel point qu'on peut faire
dans un département schéma de ruralité
que le préfet qu'on va inaugurer en
grande pompe et trois jours après la dr
film nous annonce une fermeture de
trésorerie donc nous nous souhaitons
qu'ils que le préfet sur le chef
d'orchestre de tout ça donc vous
l'initié bien avec l'ademe mais
pouvons-nous aller plus loin merci
monsieur le président merci ma main
ministre merci mr porter monsieur le
rapporteur de mathieu darnaud merci
monsieur le président moi je voudrais
simplement rebondir sur une question qui
évoquait collègues rapporteur daniel
guéret s'agissant des durée
d'expérimentation pour le transfert des
routes nationales en direction des
régions
je le dis parce que on a un peu le
sentiment dans ce pays que l'état
s'autorise et prend parfois ses aises en
termes de délais notamment lorsqu'il
demande au parlement de voter des
ordonnances et faire confiance et on l'a
vu sur l'engagement et proximité avec l'
ordonnance sur la formation des élus
locaux
je crains qu'on le voit encore s'il y a
une ordonnance que nous souhaitons pas
nous l'avons dit sur la question
essentielle pour nous en matière
d'ingénierie du cinéma mais daniel à
parler à juste raison de la durée qui
est dénoncé par toutes les régions
toutes celles que nous avons auditionné
nous disent la durée d'expérimentation
elle est beaucoup trop courte
lorsqu'il s'agit de prendre en compte
toutes les exigences qu'ils revêtent le
transfert de d'une route nationale et
j'y ajoute un autre point
c'est le délai de décision qui est
laissée aux régions de trois mois pour
savoir s'ils sont d'accord ou pas pour
l'expérimentation
alors si vous additionnez le transfert
de personnel la création pour des
régions qui n'ont pas de service dédiée
aux routes et l'expertisé parce que
quand on récupère une route nationale 3
mois c'est quand même un peu court pour
savoir les coûts qui vont devoir être
générés et puis tout ce qui concerne
j'allais dire la route en question et
les moyens qui est qu exige la reprise
de ses voix et puis cela m'amène à
parler du cinéma auquel je faisais
référence à l'instant pourquoi parce que
inévitablement lorsqu'on va transférer
des moyens en personnels et françoise
gatel il faisait référence notamment des
dire vers les départements vers les
régions et on sait s'agissant des
ouvrages ces gens des ponts par exemple
que le cirena intervient directement
auprès auprès des dires malheureusement
on risque d'avoir une incidence est une
conséquence c'est pour ça que pour nous
et vous avez raison l' ordonnance
n'empêche pas le débat mais on aimerait
quand même avoir une vision assez claire
sachant qu'il y a eu des missions
d'inspection qui ont rendu des
recommandations à la fin du mois dernier
et que nous souhaiterions savoir vers
quoi on tend parce que le serema c'est
encore ce lieu privilégié de l'état où
on a une ingénierie de haut niveau qui
permet justement de traiter et on a vu
l'actualité nous le rappelle tous les
jours les besoins que nous avons sur sur
des ouvrages sur tous ces sujets qui
font la vie quotidienne de
de nos territoires et donc même si on
comprend bien la raison sur le in house
mais qu'elles joueront ensemble que
c'est pas vraiment une raison suffisante
pour laisser à penser qu'il faille
travailler exclusivement avec le conseil
d'état et que le parlement ne saurait
être au rendez vous de ce débat là donc
voilà si vous pouvez nous éclairer sur
c'est sur ces deux questions parce que
singulièrement sur la question de la
durée d'expérimentation nous avons voté
il ya quelques mois un texte sur la
simplification de l'expérimentation ici
même au sénat et sur les délais qui sont
octroyés aux collectivités demandé aux
collectivités 3 mois pour savoir quelle
sera la décision vis-à-vis de la
proposition d'expérimentation tout ça me
paraît très courts et pour le dire très
simplement assez plus raisonnable merci
mamie je vous propose de répondre à nos
de reporter puis après je fais deux
séries de sept et huit questions par
rapport aux demandes de parole merci
d'abord il ya un point commun dans tout
ce que vous avez dit sur les histoires
de transfert de personnel
on va avoir jugé lui hier chez plus de
quoi déjà qu'il ya des manifestations
qui se préparait dans à propos des
transferts dans les dires etc
on va avoir naturellement comme à chaque
étape où on a décentralisé des choses
vous avez des oppositions systématiques
des syndicats à ça voilà c'est comme ça
une fois que c'est fait d'une manière
générale je ne vois plus de
manifestations d comme on les appelait
les tos vous rappelez je suppose que
tout le monde se rappelle de tout ça sur
la désertification médicale françoise
effectivement il ya des contributions
financières des collectivités pour tous
les établissements qui sont prévues de
toutes tailles
pour les directeurs des instituts
départementaux de l'enfance et de la
famille c'est l'article 40 les
organisations syndicales c'est vrai son
compte nous les renvoyons la semaine
prochaine
et je voulais bien évidemment te dire et
ça c'est important qui a une autre loi
qui arrivent et qui est celle de
brigitte bourguignon qui s'appelle
génération solidaire c'est ça voilà qui
va compléter et d'ailleurs je ne vais
pas plus loin dans ce texte et j'attire
ton attention sur la prise en compte du
rôle de l'état et des départements
en ce qui concerne les ehpad les
personnes à domicile etc etc
donc il y a un dans le domaine social
une prolongation qui va être fait dans
cette loi sur mathieu et puis daniel on
a des parlers excuse moi je savais pas
répondu si on si on a plus que le
problème de savoir si ces cinq ou sept
ans pour l'expérimentation
je veux dire on va pas entrer en guerre
sur un sujet comme ça hein on a mis cinq
ans parce que c'est globalement le
nombre d'années qui est souvent utilisé
dans ce genre d'expérimentations été bon
mais si toutes les régions pense que il
faut mettre un peu plus longs etc
enfin je te le dis ça fera partie du
débat parlementaire c'est pas quelque
chose qui me gêne comme pour le sénat le
serema moi je veux dire je n'ai pas de
religion
sur le fait que ça soit inscrit en dur
que ce soit par ordonnance qui est
important c'est qu'on y arrive c'est
qu'on aboutisse à ce que le serema
puisse être accessible aux collectivités
territoriales alors après nous on a fait
ça parce que tous les gens qui
m'entourent sur le plan juridique pense
que c'est plus sécurisant
bon s'il ya une écriture en dur qui
permet ça moi je vois là on verra on va
avancer avec le départ parlementaire
l'enfant moi je suis pas arc bouté sur
le fait de faire des ordonnances mais je
voudrais que vous ne soyez pas non plus
par principe arquebouté à être
conteneurs de nancy elle assure plus de
sécurité c'est tout ce que je dis tu
vois ce voilà que j'ai répondu
bien que la parole est à philippe
tabarot merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre très rapidement parce
que beaucoup de collègues veulent
intervenir je vous parlais de des
régions et de et de mobilité
quelle cohérence et quelle logique de
donner aux régions alors même sous la
forme expérimentale cinq ans ou sept ans
les tronçons de routes dont personne ne
veut même heure avec la carotte de
l'écotaxe cela n'a pas de sens
d'ailleurs cette commission a
majoritairement souhaité revoir
l'article 32 du pgl climat sur ce sujet
en face sur le ferroviaire
à mon sens la vraie question n'est pas
tant le transfert la question du
transfert
je souhaite quand même bon courage aux
régions volontaires pour gérer les infra
les gares et les personnels
la question pour nous c'est l'avenir de
ces financements et sur ce sujet les
régions n'ont aucune lisibilité au delà
de 2022 et la fan des volets transport
des décès per pouvez vous les éclairer
nous éclairer madame la ministre
j'ai peut-être remporte là plusieurs
pauvre monsieur bachy monsieur fassi
merci pour cette question pertinente et
brèves messieurs voici monsieur bachy
merci monsieur le président la ministre
je veux vous parler de la décline azur
de la déclinaison de la transition
écologique qui semble importante pour le
gouvernement et pour nos collectivités
aujourd'hui ce sont mme 40 tallec qui se
sont créés sur les territoires
c'est à l'est qui ont été créées par les
collectivités pour mieux prendre en
compte leurs besoins elle apporte une
expertise transverse et une vision à
long terme indispensable aux politiques
énergie climat
pardon
donc nous apporte une expertise
transversale et une vision à long terme
indispensable aux politiques énergie
climat par delà les alternances
politiques
enfin leur modèle permet une agilité
organisationnelles ainsi qu'une
réactivité très précieuse pour agir
localement
malgré ses atouts les élèves n'ont
bénéficié que d'une reconnaissance
tardive par la loi de transition
énergétique de 2015 et leur définition
est imparfaite celle ci laissant
notamment subissez des doutes quant aux
risques fiscaux auxquels les agences
s'expose et n'est pas suffisamment
protectrices des collectivités sur les
modalités de mise en concurrence et de
contractualisation à appliquer aussi il
apparaît nécessaire de préciser
juridiquement le modèle de ces alec afin
de reconnaître le rôle effectif est de
sécuriser leurs amis leurs activités
voilà donc je voulais mettre le doigt
sur ce sujet là qui vous d'une question
qui vous est déjà été posées par le
président de l'association des maires
françois baroin si j'ai bien parole à
monsieur me ainsi le président madame la
ministre
la consultation nationale que vient de
mener la délégation a permis de
synthétiser les attentes des élus et
dans celle ci il y à la simplification
des normes applicables et je voudrais
vous interroger sur ce point à travers
un cas concret qui celui de
l'installation d'une unité de
méthanisation petite histoire très
rapide dans les deux minutes qui me sont
impartis dans le beau département de la
somme 23 agriculteurs décide de se
lancer dans un beau projet d'unité de
méthanisation
il leur faut déposer un dossier icpe qui
donne lieu à autorisations
enregistrements et déclarations de sites
et pour remplir ce document cinq bureaux
d'études ont été nécessaires étude
paysagère études de sol études
environnementales architectes chambre
d'agriculture le tout pour cent vingt
mille euros
une analyse de sol aurait également
imposé tous les 20 hectares soit plus de
30000 euros pour les 4000 hectares
concernés comme les allées le terrain
des agriculteurs relève de 78 communes
une enquête publique est demandé sur
chacune des 78 communes comme si les
déchets et pendu pouvaient être nocifs
alors même qu un digestat issu de la
méthanisation peut être utilisé en
agriculture biologique
concernant le ruissellement comme le
site va être construit en amont damas à
vars ans il faut construire des bassins
de rétention c'est normal me direz-vous
mais il aurait demandé de dimensionner
ces bassins non pas en fonction d'une
plus décennale mais en fonction d'une
pluie centennale alors même que les
fossés ne déborderont sans doute jamais
puisque le bassin en cause est de nature
crayeuse cela accroît considérablement
les les emprises et impose la
construction d'un véritable qu'est
capable d'accueillir vous l'avez compris
l'arche de noé
enfin le temps d'instruction qui est un
minimum de 10 mois peut aller jusqu'à 18
mois au cas de recours
un technicien de la chambre
d'agriculture me confiant d'ailleurs que
les 2/3 de projet s'arrête en cours de
route à cause des difficultés
rencontrées nous avons par ailleurs un
autre projet la station photovoltaïque
et la lourdeur administrative est la
même et les délais encore plus long le
porteur de projet doit faire face un
délai de quatre ans ou cinq ans afin de
compléter son dossier d'obtenir toutes
les autorisations nécessaires
bref vous l'avez compris madame la
ministre les projets ne manquent pas
dans nos territoires
les idées sont là les ressources
mobilisables sont là les motivations
sont là les capacités à investir sont là
mais malheureusement la négation a des
limites
comment faciliter comme en face
simplifiée l'action des acteurs locaux
qui s'engagent en faveur de la
transition écologique et de l'emploi de
nos territoires
est ce que la loi cadet va nous y aider
merci chers collègues la parole et à
monsieur rejouant merci président madame
la ministre alors moi je vais parce que
je partage bien sûr tout ce qui vient
d'être dit avant et je vais focaliser
sur deux choses
est ce que vous croyez pas que
finalement par des procédures
successives on a entraîné de plus en
plus le besoin d'ingénérie c'est à dire
que nous-mêmes part je prends par
exemple l'exemple du système de l'appel
à projet qui est souvent effectivement
condamné par nos collectivités et on
pouvait il ya quelques années passées et
réalisé et préparer un projet sans avoir
besoin
donald générer aussi lourd donc je crois
que faisons attention dans ce que l'on
est capable de proposer de ne pas par
nos propres procédures générer des
besoins de dépenses financières
supplémentaires qui se peut qu'elles
soient répartis entre l'état où les
collectivités
et de toute façon c'est de l'argent
public qui est mis sur la sur la table
donc ce bois-là deuxième deuxième chose
est ce que la loi 4 les peu ou pourrait
influencer la souplesse que souhaite
obtenir les maires des petites communes
dans un département que le mien qui est
en déclin démographique
pour pouvoir bénéficier d'une certaine
liberté de 2 du permis de construire
vous savez c'est à dire avoir un lien en
fait avec la loi climat actuellement qui
a aussi ses avantages mais ces
inconvénients dans ce domaine là avec
cet objectif d'artificialisation 0 à 1
dans un délai assez assez long certes
mais qui quand même là affiché
artificialisation 0 et donc est ce que
vous pensez pas que 4 des pourrait
apporter un plus dans cette possibilité
pour les le permis de construire des
petites communes voilà merci chers
collègues je vais donner la parole en
visio un rémy pointereau rémy tu nous
entends tu as l'air figé sur terre figé
bien en attendant qu'on récupère rémy
pointereau je vais donner la parole à
madame préville merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
merci de nous écouter et de nous
répondre alors moi je vais à rome je
vais revenir sur les la désertification
médicale
parce que dans mon département nord du
lot 48 mille habitants un gynécologue un
pédiatre très peu de femmes au logist et
la plupart des habitants vont se faire
soigner ailleurs
et si en est juste à renouveler les
spécialistes et médecins qui sont censés
être là actuellement on n'y arrivera pas
parce qu'on n'est déjà pas à la maille
de ce qui existe sur le reste du
territoire les gynécologues ce serait
vite qu'on devrait avoir
alors on nous avons inscrit dans la loi
au sénat
là nous avons inscrit donc l'obligation
de stages pour les étudiants en médecine
or ce je pense que c'est un décret qui
n'a toujours pas été pris donc je vous
lance une petite requête
c'est d'essayer de faire en sorte que
ceci parce que soit appliquée parce que
nous l'avons inscrit dans la loi
l'obligation de ces stages parce que ce
serait un levier très important parce
qu'on le sait le noeud du problème c'est
de faire en sorte que les médecins
viennent sur les territoires et les
spécialistes et ce sera un levier très
important pour que nous puissions
obtenir par ce qu'ont bien sûr on nous
l'avons inscrit dans la loi parce qu'on
imagine bien qu'un cas un étudiant en
médecine qui vient faire un stage dans
un territoire serait peut-être amenés à
rester parce qu'il s'y plierait voilà et
comment est la deuxième question c'est
comment faire pour associer un petit peu
plus les élus des territoires qui
connaissent bien leur territoire et qui
serait à même de proposer des solutions
quand on est à évaluer les besoins et
les projections qu'on peut faire sur le
recrutement des médecins et sur les
études de médecine merci steam préville
monsieur houlgate
merci président merci madame la ministre
l'article 47 du projet de loi donc donne
une valeur législative au contrat de
cohésion territoriale afin de concourir
donc à la bonne coordination des
politiques publiques dans une approche
transversale dont je me suis dit tiens
c'est super c'est ni plus ni moins ce
que préconisait le rapport morvan avec
le contrat unique
donc j'ai deux questions la première c
est ce que les contrats de réalité vont
disparaître et puis la deuxième il ya un
nouvel objet qui est apparu dans le
paysage de la contractualisation c'est
le contrat de relance et de transition
écologique dont on nous dit lorsque la
carte des 833 périmètre a été publié
mais qu'ils sont destinés à porter les
projets de territoire pour les six
années de mandat municipal et
intercommunal en cours
donc est-ce que ce contrat de cohésion
territoriale est mort-né et qu'elle va
être fin de compte ça portait son
ampleur à ce que les autres contrats
vont disparaître et quid de
l'articulation notamment du volet
territorial du cer et des fonds
européens qui sont en cours de deux
d'élaboration en ce moment merci
monsieur au gatt madame la ministre je
vous propose de répondre mais cette
collègue sur les routes
d'abord sur les routes
la question ah oui oui ça y est les
routes
d'abord c'est sur le volontariat on
force personne à prendre des routes y
compris pour les routes départementales
mais je vous dis entre parenthèses que
c'est une demande des départements de
récupérer des morceaux ou des tronçons
si je puis dire de route qu'il reste
nationale alors que les deux autres
bouts par ailleurs son départementale
donc c'est une demande qui est très bien
sur l'expérimentation l'expérimentation
c'est pareil la première région qui nous
a demandé cette expérimentation c'est la
région grand est est la région grand est
est partante parce que évidemment parce
que l'espace des régions maintenant et
dell qu' il y à des régions qui sont
intéressés par la prise de gestion des
routes nationales
mais encore une fois rien ne les y
oblige et tout ça fait partie de
contractualisation avec l'état et vous
avez soulevé le sujet des moyens bien
évidemment les moyens
vous le savez sur le volet actuel des
cpe m ce qui concerne les routes a été
prolongé de deux ans jusqu'à 2022 et il
y a à nouveau volet qui est prévu pour
les infrastructures routières dans les
contrats de plan état région entre 2023
et 2027 et le conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures a commencé à travailler
avec les projets qui sont avancés par
les collectivités territoriales
et bien sûr cela fera partie de
contractualisation dans les cpe m je
voudrais aussi insisté sur le fait que
les contrats de plan état région sont
jumelées avec des contrats de relance si
je puis dire est que il y a dans les
deux premières années parfois des
financements qui ont été apportées dans
les contrats de relance sur des tronçons
de route
dans certaines régions et le reste
viendra bien sûr dans les négociations
et les contrats de plan et en régions
ont des clauses de revoyure qui nous
permettront d'intégrer le volet le volet
route donc d'une manière générale les
collectivités territoriales sont plutôt
satisfaites de deux de ses de ses
propositions
voilà en ce we sur l' agence locale de
l'énergie je vous remercie
je pense que vous avez raison et on est
tout à fait prêt à travailler avec vous
sur sur ce sujet pour voir si par un
amendement il faut sécuriser davantage
ces agences de l'énergie moi je je ne
vois pas d'inconvénient à cela / je
prends stéphane demi bon plus les
questions d'après vous m'avez posé
beaucoup de questions qui relèvent de la
loi climat et du ministère de la
transition écologique
alors j'ai un conseil à vous donner
régler le maximum de problèmes dans la
loi climat jeu parce que je l ai fait
pour ça bah parce que comme j'ai un peu
comme j'ai un peu le sens
non parce que je crains qu'on se dise ah
ben si ça va pas là on va régler le
problème dans la loi qui suit quoi si je
puis dire
mais plus vous avancez dans la loi
climat mieux ça vaut alors je ne suis
pas naïve
je sais bien que peut-être s'il ya des
choses qui sont pas qu'ils sont encore
perfectibles à votre avis qui en a qui
arriveront dans la loi le cadre des j'ai
bien conscience de ça mais il faut il
faut essayer de 2 comment dire de régler
le maximum de sujets mais quand
j'entends ce que tu dis pour la
méthanisation là évidemment qu'il faut
simplifier beaucoup de choses et qu'il y
à des procédures qu'il faut simplifier
et il y en a qui ne relèvent pas
évidemment de la loi c'est des
procédures qui sont des procédures qui
relève du fonctionnement interne des
ministères et des réglementations qui
sont installés dans les ministères
bon et je reconnais monsieur le sénateur
parce qu'il ya une part de vérité dans
ce que vous avez dit sur l'ingénierie
est ce qu'on crée pas nous
le besoin d'en générer au fond c'est ça
vous avez dit alors je dirais oui et non
parce que vous voyez par exemple
d'ailleurs ces parties du sénat on en a
parlé beaucoup on fait un programme
ponts avec l' agence nationale de
cohésion des territoires pour aider les
collectivités territoriales à voir si
les ponts qu'elles ont dont elles sont
propriétaires dans les communes et
cetera sont encore c'est que
suffisamment sécurisé bas si vous voulez
il faut des ingénieurs
char en charge de des oeuvres d'art si
je puis dire pour pour pourra être
compétent des ingénieurs béton etc etc
donc ça je dirais une et on est dans une
société comme vous le savez qui admet de
mois en mois je ne sais pas comment dire
les accidents entre guillemets et c'est
à dire tous doite est hyper sécurisé
donc la population demande vraiment la
sécurité partout et donc on a besoin
aussi d'ingénierie mais je reconnais que
l'appel à projet qui est utilisé trop
souvent par un certain nombre de
ministères ne facilite pas les choses
en ce qui me concerne voyez par exemple
pour le plan de relance nous dans mon
ministère nous avons tous des concentrés
dans les mains des préfets et c'est
quand même mieux quand tu es préfet au
plus près du terrain
finances par la d6 l'exceptionnel la des
cils qui est consacrée à la transition
énergétique
c'est toujours mieux parce que plus et
en proximité plus ça va vite
il faut qu'on apprenne et je peux vous
dire que le président de la république
et le premier ministre ne cesse de dire
aux administrations et donc au mini au
ministre qui sont responsables de leur
administration fait en sorte que tout
cela soit au maximum déconcentrer
d'abord parce que les appels à projets
on sait aussi qu'elle ça favorise
toujours les grandes communes et au
désavantage des petites communes qui
n'ont pas toujours la haine générique
techniques pour répondre aux appels à
projets je prends un exemple concret
deux exemples concrets qui vont dans ce
sens vous savez qu'il ya un ségur de la
santé vous savez qu'il va y avoir dans
le ségur de la santé des augmentations
de salaires etc mais va y avoir aussi
des crédits pour l'investissement des
des hôpitaux et le premier ministre a
décidé que c'est c'est comment dire ces
crédits seraient déconcentrés dans les
mains des préfets
alors je vous parle pas de la
construction de l'hôpital de nantes
parce que ça c'est un autre sujet mais
les travaux faits dans les hôpitaux les
petits hôpitaux ruraux etc qui sont très
importants et de proximité ce sera des
concentrés donc il y a il ya d'autres
domaines les pistes cyclables par
exemple premier ministre veut aussi des
concentrés tout ce qui est financement
des des pistes cyclables etc etc
on est vraiment dans cette démarche et
c'est vrai que c'est plus simple est
qu'il faut amplifier
alors ensuite sur les stages madame en
médecine bien évidemment je suis
d'accord avec vous d'ailleurs les stages
chez qu'une chose je sais pas cette
histoire de ce décret c'est pas mon
ministère je vais regarder je vais
regarder parce que je
je sais pas si un décret qui est en
attente je vais regarder moi il ya un
autre truc auquel je crois et qu'on a et
qu'il faut développer
à mon avis ça avait été décidé aussi par
agnès buzyn je crois que c'est important
moi quand j'étais jeune et a longtemps
j'étais prof peut-être le savez vous on
pouvait passer un truc qui s'appelait
les ipes c'est à dire qu'on était payées
pendant nos études et au sortir de nos
études on devait dix ans c'était ça à
l'époque de notre vie et on nous disait
vous allez à enseigner à
saint-amand-montrond ça c'est pour mon
ami qui fut ga
et les plus figé les plus figée et bah
on allait à saint-amand n'ont pas donc
je pense que cette histoire qui a été
décidé par agnès buzyn doit être doit se
multiplier parce que c'est vrai que
quand on met des jeunes sur des
territoires où qu'il y à des stages
parfois je les ai vus dans mon
département loir et cher qu'à une
carence médical très importante des
jeunes qui viennent en stage finalement
je pense à cheverny par exemple
connaissent et cheverny évidemment bas
le stagiaire il est resté voilà et ça
fait un médecin et donc il faut
effectivement trouvé toutes ces méthodes
pour attirer les jeunes sur les
territoires
mais il faut aussi qu' il y ait les
postes ouverts d'un terne dans les chu
enfin tout ça est très compliqué enfin
c'est un sujet qui est très bien les crt
eux
vous m'avez posé la question
la contractualisation et évidemment
comme vous le savez j'ai bien aimé un
jour j'ai entendu jean pierre raffarin
qui connaît comme nous tous bien cette
maison qui a dit cette phrase la
contractualisation c'est la
décentralisation d'aujourd'hui et je
trouve que c'est assez juste parce que
dans la contractualisation l'état et les
collectivités territoriales se mettent
d'accord sur des politiques et au fond
sur la manière de développer des
politiques publiques sur les territoires
et naturellement les crt eux ont
vocation à être des contrats
intégrateurs c'est ça la question que
vous posiez monsieur je crois est
aujourd'hui dans la loi il existe un
seul contrat c'est les contrats de ville
et qui sont dans une loi fait plus
laquelle la loi 2014 les contrats de
ville sont dans la loi autrement il n'y
a pas de contrat de en dur dans le droit
ce que nous voulons c'est effectivement
que ccrt e contrat de relance et de
transition énergétique mais aussi le
premier ministre l'a écrit dans sa
circulaire du 20 novembre contrat de
ruralité transition écologique g10
énergétique c'est écologique pardon
parce que les contrats de ruralité
arrive à échéance ils sont terminés donc
on les remplace par les crt eux
alors on dit contrat de relance qu'en ce
moment il ya la relance et qu'il faut
que les intercommunalités bénéficie
aussi de la relance mais dans les zones
rurales
on perd mais que ça s'appelle toujours
contrat de ruralité et de transition
écologique
donc oui c'est un contrat intégrateurs
dans laquelle sur un périmètre qui est
l'intercommunalité ou plusieurs
intercommunalités
on perd mais la contractualisation sur
toutes les politiques publiques entre
l'état et les collectivités
territoriales
est ce que j'ai répondu à votre question
non mais quelle est l'articulation avec
les contrats de cohésion territoriale
qui sont prévus dans la loi l'article 47
mais c'est la même chose c'est à dire
que les contrats de cohésion
territoriale vont devront se substituer
aux contrats de relance et de transition
écologique
et qu il
c'est la même chose mais vous avez
raison c'est pas très clair donc on va
on va vous avez raison je ça m'avait pas
oui parce que quand on dit contrat de
relance et de transition écologique on a
des six ans parce qu'il ya la relance
mais en fait et compte les contrats de
cohésion de territoire sera la même
chose
voilà mais simplement à me relancer
comme vers leur la relance est limité
voyez bon j'ai pas très clair
effectivement j'ai répondu à tous là non
alors on va on va continuer
effectivement ya ya ya un sujet qui
revient régulièrement et je pense qu'il
reviendra en question qui vont arriver
c'est super c'est pas facile parce que
ça fait des années qu'on en parle mais
on n'arrive pas à régler problème c'est
effectivement de simplifier quoi c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qui est je
crois que je l'avais dit quand on a fait
la loi à zap
en conclusion de la loi âmes j'avais dit
il ya quelque chose de compliqué c'est
simplifier et je crois que c'est simple
de compliqué on va donner la parole à
rémy pointereau oui oui merci monsieur
le président désolé tout à l'heure c'est
ce sont les les joies du haut débit dans
l'est dans le monde rural madame la
ministre cheikh jacqueline ouy
concernant donc cette audition je
voulais poser une question sur le fait
que en fait le problème de de cette
déconcentration décentralisation quand
on lit la description sur le site
internet de votre ministère il est
indiqué que cette décentralisation est
fondée sur les propositions des acteurs
locaux
et pourtant à lire les dispositions du
projet de loi j'ai le sentiment qu'une
réclamation qui était fortement demandés
par les élus locaux de la paye droit à
votre oreille attentive
il s'agit
en effet comme le souvent si la
compétence je m'habille et plus présents
précisément le volet pays c'est-à-dire
prévention des inondations et madame
l'ami je ne compte plus le nombre de
délibérations que j'ai reçu de conseil
communautaire de mon département
d'autres départements pour contester a
raison
l'application de cette compétence les
communautés de communes qui sont situés
sur les bords de loire comme l'est le
val d'aubois halle berry loire govies
etc et le pays sancerrois contesté déjà
en 2020 la convention entre l'état et et
ces intercommunalités portant sur le
transfert de compétences chez mappy et
c'est parce qu'il est incompréhensible
de leur demander de financer le
renouvellement de dick qui n'ont jamais
entretenu par l'état et avec un système
qui lie le linéaire de digues au nombre
d'habitants de la communauté de communes
finalement on s'aperçoit en d'autres
termes sur la loire notamment le montant
des travaux de structure entretien
courant est le même pour un jeu pc de
6000 habitants que pour une
agglomération où une métropole de 2 200
mille trois cent mille habitants alors
c'est tout simplement irréalisable et
irréaliste pour le pci rural et en
conséquence dans mon département un
certain nombre de communautés de
communes ont décidé et ils ont bien sûr
tout mon soutien de ne pas régulariser
les systèmes indique mme en faute de
moyens financiers
ma question est simple et puisque nous
ne pouvons pas apparemment déposé un
amendement effectué un transfert de
compétences au risque de tomber dans
l'irrecevabilité à l'article 40 de la
constitution
envisagez vous d'agir sur ce volet dans
le cadre de ce projet de loi parce que
cette compétence prévention et notation
devrait revenir à l'état ou tout au
moins
à l'échelon régional pour les fleuves ou
un établissement public concernant le
fleuve où aller son département
si ça il s'agit de rivière de moniales
moi je pense qu'il faut vraiment revoir
cette compétence j'aime api dans cette
loi à 4d parce que ça pose de vrais
problèmes pour nos communautés de
communes rurales notamment
t'as pas eu l'idée de mettre ça dans la
loi climat est ce que c'est c'est de la
transition écologique
oui enfin c'est de la transition à jeux
écologiques c'est une compétence quand
même qui coûte très cher à nos à nos
communautés de communes quand vous avez
des digues de loire qui n'ont jamais été
entretenue par l'état et qu'on est
d'accord je menais enfin bon
rémy je vois bien le sujet et pour être
pour être connaisseur
alors j'en aurais je veux pas rappeler à
certains qui étaient déjà là quand la
loi j'aime mappy a été votée enfin quand
je dis la loi j'aime api l'amendement
qui a créé chez mappy
au détour d'une loi qui devait être la
loi date un autre on voit bien quand les
trucs sont pas aussi enfin moi je me
permets de dire ça un camp c'était un
amendement sénatorial qui a créé gema
pis quand les choses sont pas
suffisamment étudié préparer anticipé
aussi je rappelle que je suis depuis que
je suis ministre j'ai déjà reçu une loi
sur l'âge et mappy à la demande des
régions et des départements
nous avons ouvert la capacité de
financement aux départements et aux
régions des sujets dont tu es en train
de parler et c'était la demande gêne
j'ai une idée très à souvenirs très
précis puisque dominique bussereau
président de l'adf demandé à pouvoir
poursuivre la construction de protection
des digues maritimes
suite à la tempête xynthia
je me rappelle très précisément donc
nous avons ouvert au département puis
aux régions
et je sais que c'est quelque chose qui
est donc très lourd pour les
collectivités territoriales et moi
personnellement je pense que la seule
solution c'est la mutualisation de cette
compétence au niveau 2 les pl de
l'établissement public loire
moi je te donne mon avis mon avis
personnel là parce que autrement on s'en
sortira pas si c'est d'abord trop
morcelé et puis sur le plan financier on
aura besoin effectivement du soutien de
l'état des collectivités territoriales
mais bon voilà j'ai c'est vrai qu'il ya
rien de prévu sur ce sujet dans le texte
bah oui merci mais c'est bien c'est pas
parce qu'il ya eu d'erreur un moment
donné ou une mauvaise interprétation ou
un mollet n'étaient pas suffisamment
calais qu'il faut pas aujourd'hui revoir
les choses enfin c'est le moment on peut
et on peut en discuter aussi avec le
ministère de la transition écologique
un merci l'ami doit partir un 10h10 dans
qu'il nous reste 35 minutes et j'ai
encore vu question monsieur demi naze
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre
le président aux jo a commencé notre
échange en parlant du serema dont je
voudrais revenir moi sur le sur le
serema pour le moment sur le plan
budgétaire il n'y a aucune inflexion sur
le processus de réduire les effectifs de
du sert et m'a donc ma première question
c'est comment un gouvernement peut en
même temps faciliter la saisine du sert
et ma part les collectivités tout en
réduisant les effectifs et les
investissements de cette structure dans
votre exposé vous nous avez indiqué que
la mct à une convention avec le serema
une convention qui l'engagent peu là
excepté sur le plan financier et qui à
ma connaissance n'est toujours pas signé
or la snc lines et et a demandé aux
serema des expertises qui ne sont
toujours pas payés donc comment vous
pouvez expliquer et comment cela est
possible comment vous pouvez nous
expliquer cette situation
enfin dans la loi 3ds il est question de
permettre aux collectivités de
tombouctou 3ds alors 4d si vous voulez
ou en 3d ce que je ne sais pas d'où ça
sort ouais bon c'est pas l'objet de la
question
non mais je me permets de réagir donc
dans la loi qui nous permet de nous
rencontrer
il est question de permettre aux
collectivités de passer par le ser emma
et si j'ai bien compris
sans la procédure des marchés qui me
semble une une avancée pour autant
est-ce qu'il n'ya pas à terme une
ouverture pour une forme de
régionalisation des structures du serena
avec un désengagement de l'état
merci je vais donner un visio la parole
à monsieur marchand
on ne tente un pas faut que tu mets ton
micro et frédéric en ne tentant pas
foutu métaux l'écran pardon excusez moi
effectivement oui merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
bonjour moi j'ai une question qui fait
suite à des échanges récents avec une
intercommunalité de mon département au
sujet de la mise en place du mécanisme
qui est contenu dans la loi et dans le
mise en place de mécanismes de cotations
des demandes de logement social pour le
1er septembre 2021 puisque pour cette
intercommunalité qui veut bien
évidemment respecter la loi ça semble un
tantinet le prématuré et je sais que le
gouvernement a saisi au début du mois de
mai le conseil national de l'habitat
dans le cadre du projet de loi 4d pour
adapter le calendrier de mise en oeuvre
de la cotation de demande de logement
social et vous demander si vous confirme
effectivement que la volonté prévoir un
report des échéances de cette cotation à
fin 2023 ce qui arrangerait nombre
d'intercommunalités merci beaucoup merci
chers collègues je vais un parent la
manne un filleul je vous remercie
monsieur le président madame la ministre
merci de répondre à nos questions moi je
voulais vous poser les trois 3 questions
la première consiste à revenir sur ce
qui m'apparaît comme un paradoxe ou une
contradiction à savoir que vous dites
que votre projet de loi n'est pas le
grand soir que nous avons besoin de
stabilité dans nos institutions
ce que je partage complètement comme
analyse et en même temps vous proposer
que les routes nationales soient
transférées aux régions alors qu'elles
n'ont pas l'expertisé qu'elles n'ont pas
le savoir faire dans le domaine alors
que les départements eux ont une
ancienneté et au contraire ce savoir
faire et cette expertise
alors vous me dites vous dites vous
répondait à mes collègues que c'est à la
demande de ces collectivités
territoriales concernées sauf que moi je
lis dans la presse et je rencontre aussi
des collectivités qui disent qu'elles ne
sont pas intéressés par ce transfert
il en est de même de la tutelle des
régions sur les départements à propos de
la biodiversité alors que les
départements gère depuis des décennies
des espaces naturels
ciblant les préservant et en les ouvrant
également au public
donc comment comment expliquer cette
contradiction vraiment je suis très
intéressé par votre explication
le deuxième point sur lequel je voulais
venir c'est celui de lille etc trop
nisme car votre gouvernement certes fait
beaucoup dans le domaine entre les
conseillers numérique les passe au
numérique les aigles numérique
les 250 millions d'euros je crois qu'on
monte noter la haine s'était cependant
quand on est sur le terrain on voit bien
que tout tout ce travail finalement ne
ne touche pas directement les plus
concernés je pense aux passes formation
par exemple seulement 20 % d'entre eux
sont effectivement utilisées pour faire
de la formation
or le coc vide a montré qu'il y avait
vraiment une rupture d'égalité quand nos
concitoyens ne sont pas ne sont pas
branchés sur le numérique ne sont pas
initiés au numérique
ne pensez-vous pas que votre loi aurait
pu faire l'objet au moins d'une mention
d'un chef d'orchestre peut-être pas d'un
chef de file je sais que vous n'aimez
pas cette expression mais au moins qu'il
y ait une collectivité qui veille à ce
que cette politique soit bien répartie
territorialement parce qu'aujourd'hui
nous n'avons aucun moyen d'évaluer les
territoires qui sont effectivement doté
ceux qui ne le seront pas parce qu'on
est sur la base du bénévolat de une
certaine dynamique associative qui
existent ou qui n'existe pas dans
certains territoires dont je trouve que
dans ce domaine il ya un peu une
occasion ratée si vous me le permettez
le troisième point est plus plus
marginale on va dire et concerne
l'article 11
mes interlocuteurs à vnf me disent
qu'ils pointent une anomalie puisque les
prises et légal d'eau et de rejet d'eau
vont être pénalisés en fonction de la
situation économique de l'auteur qui est
pénalisé en quelque sorte et donc il
trouve que c'est quand même une une
surprise une anomalie dans notre droit
français merci monsieur chevrolet puis
après la ministre répondra merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je salue vos propos introductif avec les
mots proximité en état territoriale de
proximité une meilleure prise en compte
des particularités locales qui s'adapte
le mieux aux territoires et puis cette
attente forte de simplification à la
fois des élus et des acteurs économiques
et nos concitoyens mais je relève un
certain nombre de contradictions
notamment sur le sujet des espaces
france service ou là sont des objectifs
qui qui tombe de l'état pour des
implantations dans les territoires avec
une vraie justification est un vrai
intérêt pour nos concitoyens mais pas
toujours en cohérence avec les attentes
locales et des objectifs parfois qui
sont pas calé avec les opci c'est vrai
que si vous l'avez dit c'est les cantons
mais l' approche par pci semble plus
pertinente qui je rappelle aussi que ces
espaces france service il ya quand même
un problème de moyens aussi et la
contribution des collectivités locales
puisque le reste à charge reste à 50%
je voulais également revenir sur la
question des des appels à projets
nombreux qui sont compliquées pour les
collectivités locales et à séparer les
appels à projets il tombe du haut vers
le bas ils partent pas des projets de
territoire et notamment pour les petites
communes
je pense notamment un sujet qui vous est
cher sur les tiers lieux j'étais encore
à quelques jours d'une commune qui est
rural qui veut développer un tiers lieux
assez compliqué de tomber dans l'appel à
projets du gouvernement ou et que dire
des contrats de relance transition
écologique et petites villes de demain
qui recycle des dispositions mais qui
sont pas toujours adaptées au projet et
ils sont pas toujours non plus dans la
temporalité des attentes du territoire
et sur ces contrats qui seront parfois
contraignant sur le plan financier
que dire sur la probable est-ce que vous
parlez de la probable saison 2 des
contrats de cahors qui imposeront aussi
des contraintes financières à ses élus
et enfin dernier point dans votre projet
il serait prévu une recentralisation
dans certains domaines et notamment dans
le secteur de l'eau
renforçant le rôle du préfet
coordinateur de bassin qui se verrait
systématiquement confier la présidence
du conseil d'administration des agences
de l'eau les représentants des élus
voient dans cette mesure prévue dans le
projet de loi risque de déstabilisation
des comités de bassin
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez leur répondre
merci madame la ministre madame la
ministre je vous propose de répondre à
mes collègues merci
alors sur le serema monsieur sur le
serema votre inquiétude alors vous avez
noté une contradiction sur les postes et
l'ambition que l'on veut donner aux
serema c'est la raison pour laquelle il
faut ouvrir le serema aux collectivités
territoriales et le serena est sous la
tutelle du maire vous à dire que je fais
une fixette du ministère de la
transition écologique et si vous voulez
le meilleur façon monsieur le sénateur
de sauver le serema et d'en faire un
outil qui se maintient avec des postes
maintenus
c'est de lui donner une vocation
nouvelle d'ouverture aux collectivités
territoriales je le dis avec le plie
d'élégance possible et je serai là pour
me battre pour que les postes soient
maintenues bien sûr le serment à signer
et s'est passé devant les conseils
d'administration je pourrais je parle
devant louis jean de nicolaÿ qui
pourrait le certifier le
ces patients conseil d'administration de
la haine c'est et il y à des conventions
et un travail coordonné entre l' agence
nationale de cohésion des territoires et
et le
le ser et m'a eu
on cherche donc je dirais un équilibre
économique
avec ce in house qui facilitera donc le
travail des collectivités et bien sûr le
serema sera rémunérée par les
collectivités
bien évidemment pour le travail fait
voilà je ne sais pas si j'ai
suffisamment répondu à vos
interrogations
ou est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui
vous je n'ai pas été encore assez
précise témoin les informations que je
puisse que j'ai visités avec vous le
siège du séré maragon oui dans le
territoire je représente ici au sénat et
je connais votre engagement par rapport
à 7 mois la rupture et que je partage
oui oui bien cela dit les éléments dont
je dispose sur avec les contacts des
organisations syndicales c'est qu'à ma
connaissance avec la s est à la haine
c'est lé là où les conventions ne sont
pas signés voilà je ne vous souhaite pas
dernière question ne sont pas signés
c'est des éléments que j'ai ça j'ai
peut-être un truc administratif un jouet
j'ai bien entendu
ou alors la réponse soit la premier
point sur la nécessité du seimat sourire
aux collectivités territoriales si on
veut sauver ce type de structure
maintenant je vous ai posé une troisième
question c'était dans cette procédure
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une possibilité ou
une volonté une ouverture de
régionaliser les différentes structures
du cema avec un désengagement de l'état
écoutez ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
quelque chose qui qui aujourd'hui
est dans les tuyaux si je puis dire et
personne ne nous ne nous a jamais
proposé
cela et c'est une agence qui dépense est
un service de l'état
je veux dire je pense que l'étape
première c'est de continuer à faire
exister c'est tout cet outil technique
très important et est pour l'instant
nous n'avons pas envisagé ce sujet voilà
ensuite sur l'article sur les voies
navigables de france
il a été rédigé à la demande de vnf afin
de mieux protéger le domaine public
fluvial
aujourd'hui la sanction est plafonné à
1500 euros pour certains ce n'est pas du
tout dissuasif l'objectif du
déplafonnement de la sanction est de
mettre fin à cette pratique et donc de
protéger davantage
voilà c'est quelque chose que nous avons
fait en concertation avec vnf oui
bon on peut j'entends ce que vous dites
on regardera ça si vous voulez bien
voilà vous avez évoqué aussi ma d'un
filleul la contradiction je ne vois pas
quelle est la contradiction au sujet des
routes et des de l'expérimentation aux
régions j'entends ce que vous avez dit
jusqu'ici les routes étaient transférées
au département c'était une compétence
départementale
bon c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
l'avons mis en expérimentation et non
pas en transferts
comme vous pouvez le voir j'entends ce
que vous dites et j'étais sûr que
quelqu'un me poserai la question mais ça
n'est pas un bouleversement énorme et en
même temps l'état a aussi des routes
d'intérêt national qu'il n'est pas prêt
à décentraliser parce que ça traverse la
france entière
donc voilà je crois que il n'y a pas de
contradiction sur vous avait parlé de
tutelle de biodiversité
il n'y a pas de tutelle de la région
les espaces naturels sensibles restent
dans les mains des départements voilà
sur le numérique
j'ai entendu ce que vous dites mais vous
savez comment dire je sais bien que la
recherche de l'efficacité et de ré de
collectivités responsables de tel ou tel
domaine
nous faisons je vous remercie d'avoir
reconnu que nous faisions beaucoup pour
le numérique et les collectivités jouent
un rôle très important les france
service
les tirs lieu dont monsieur parlais tout
à l'heure
plus ça se répand sur le territoire
l'inclusion numérique l'accompagnement
numérique
c'est important alors dire dans la loi
qui est responsable de ça vous savez je
me rappelle des débats homériques sur la
culture sur le sport il ya quand même
des compétences qu'il est parfois
difficile d'attribuer définitivement à
un niveau de collectivités territoriales
vous vous rappelez quand il enfin
certains qui étaient là pour la loi
notre canton n'a dit à qui on donne la
culture alors là ça a été la foire
d'empoigné
et d'ailleurs on n'a jamais donné la
culture à un niveau de collectivités
territoriales on l'a laissé à tous les
niveaux de co2 collectivités
territoriales donc j'entends ce que vous
dites mais pour l'instant je crois pas
que ça soit raisonnable de le faire
voilà mais admettez que l'état peut
jouer un rôle pour encourager l'ensemble
des collectivités à s'y engager sur les
les français service monsieur le
sénateur vous avez dit que les opci
était souvent la halle à l'échelle
pertinente je suis d'accord avec vous
d'ailleurs
sur les fronts service nous les faisons
alors j'ai plus les chiffres en tête en
tête mais les partenaires
bien sûr en premier ce sont les
collectivités territoriales et en
premier ce sont les communes et les
intercommunalités qui sont les porteurs
de
de france service et naturellement nous
accompagnons les élus qui sont
volontaires et il ya des français rvices
dans toute la france après qu'ils
portent les français service on à la
poste on à la mutualité sociale agricole
qui porte aussi des francs services en
tant que porteurs de projets et et d'une
manière générale je dirais ça se passe
plutôt bien
et naturellement nous sommes et nous
demandons au préfet dans chaque
département de avec les élus locaux de
regarder quels sont les lieux où il y
aurait besoin de francs services et de
nous faire remonter les volontés des
élus locaux
c'est comme ça qu'on fonctionne bon
c'est comme les tirs lieu je finis par
les tirs lui aussi parce que on lance
pas d'appel à projets pour les tiers
lieux les tiens non on a fait des appels
à projets pour les pour les oublier le
nom comment fabrique des territoires
merci fabrique des territoires c'est à
dire on a fait des appels à projets pour
des tiers lieux qui veulent être moteur
pour un territoire pour créer pour
l'essaimage de tiers lieu si je puis
dire
mais autrement je participe très de très
près à la création de tir lieu qui émane
de la volonté territoriale et qu'on
accompagne
voilà j'ai cahors 2 qu'est-ce qui m'a
posé la question du cas hors de ces vous
aussi monsieur jeu je crois que personne
ne me réclame des cas hors d'eux
et que naturellement il sera bien temps
qu'un jour le ministère de l'économie et
du budget nous reparle de ces choses
mais comme vous le savez cahors a été
suspendue depuis la crise de l'aco vide
et évidemment les dépenses qui ont été
engagés par les collectivités
territoriales
voilà sur les agences de l'eau le préfet
coordonne et coordonnateur de bassin et
président lagence de l'eau c'est au fond
le renforcement du rôle des préfets dans
l'élaboration du programme pluriannuel
d'intervention de chaque agence ainsi le
préfet le garant de la cohérence de
l'action des services de l'état sur le
territoire
le préfet coordonnateur de base
surveillera la vie des préfet de chaque
département pour prendre en compte bien
sur les projets locaux et les
préoccupations des élus
qu'est ce que j'ai oublié
pardon qu'est-ce-qui jacobins alors non
alors je veux c'est compliqué parce que
à la fois ci je voulais vous dites c'est
jacobins t'ai dit tout à l'heure que les
préfets soient les coordinateurs de
toutes les agences xy qui existent sur
les territoires bah si c'est souvent ce
qu'on nous demande mais peut-être pas
vous mais c'est souvent ce qu'on nous
demande est aussitôt qu'on ramène à peu
le préfet dans le sujet fort on nous dit
vous êtes jacobins et sages femmes
moi je crois que c'est un faux problème
un jacobinisme et girondins crois que
c'est un faux à faux problème mais je je
je crois que les préfets sont aussi les
garant de l'équité ce que tout le monde
nous demande
je vais donner la parole parce qu'il
nous reste encore cinq demandes de
parole et guy novès dix minutes un
monsieur vidéo merci monsieur le
président c'est mieux écoutez je crois
que je suis en plein dans l'actualité et
mal intervention tombe à pic
à propos de ce que vient de dire madame
la ministre moi je m'interroge en tant
que sénateur membre du conseil
d'administration de l'ademe
je m'interroge sur une disposition
contenue à l'article 45 qui donne au
préfet de région le rôle de délégué
territorial de l'ademe
en clair vous déléguez au préfet de
région le pouvoir de négocier et de
conclure au nom de l' agence toute
convention avec les collectivités
locales et leurs groupements
je connais bien la dame pour avoir
travaillé avec elle lors de mon mandat
d'élu local aux ponts-de-cé est
aujourd'hui au conseil d'administration
j'ai le sentiment que cette agence
fonctionne à plein régime et représente
un interlocuteur de confiance pour les
élus les acteurs économiques associatifs
j'en veux pour preuve la consommation
rapide et total de ses crédits dans un
délai record pour l'année 2001 cette
disposition
ou plutôt cette recentralisation ne
risque-t-elle pas de désorganiser ou
d'enrayer une agence qui tourne à plein
régime
n'y at il pas un risque de perdre une
neutralité dans les prises de décision
une neutralité fortement apprécié par
les élus qui pour la transition
écologique sont capables de dépasser les
clivages partisans pour l'intérêt
général
ne croyez-vous pas troubler ce cercle
vertueux patiemment construit par les
équipes de cette agence dont on peut
aujourd'hui tous se féliciter et ce
malgré les suppressions de postes à ma
connaissance ce ne sont pas les
associations d'élus qui ont inspiré
cette évolution qui il faut bien le dire
est une étatisation rampante de l'ademe
il qui est contraire à l'esprit de
décentralisation dans ce projet de loi
on a du mal parfois à percevoir tous
l'aider est ce que vous pouviez nous ce
que vous pourriez nous éclairer madame
la ministre dans le cadre de nos futurs
débats et savoir si vous êtes disposés à
modifier vos positions sur la nécessité
de renforcer cette agence et non de
l'affaiblir je vous remercie
merci monsieur jacques 1 et après madame
demain monsieur l'antec et monsieur de
nicolay merci président madame la
ministre
deux questions les maisons france
services sont un dispositif que
j'apprécie après les msa paix à
condition qu' on y mettre les moyens et
la qualité et que ce ne soit pas
un désengagement véritable mais je pense
que ces outils peuvent être pertinents
dans mon département la commission des
élus à l'abeille terre avait proposé aux
services de l'état qu'on accompagne au
maximum ces maisons france services en
matière d'investissement faisant en
sorte que le l'autofinancement soit 20 %
pour les collectivités et là on voit
qu'après toutes les annonces du plan de
relance ou même certains élus espérer
faire le le jackpot est bien au moment
de l'instruction des dossiers on est
plutôt sur des positions de repli
j'ai en tête un dossier mais en france
service assez important après 3 millions
d'euros ou l'état nous dit finalement
ben j'ai peut-être plus la possibilité
de mettre l'intégralité et puis des
financements complémentaires ont été
trouvés je viens pas sur mon dossier
mais d'une manière générale je pense que
ces dispositifs la maison france service
c'est pas comme une école c'est pas
comme un autre équipement public c'est
vraiment les services publics ont plus
proche des usagers
la deuxième question est relative aux
titres transition écologique transport à
plusieurs reprises tant philippe tabarot
que martine filleul vous ont questionné
sur la cohérence de cette
expérimentation transfert des routes
autant on comprend qu'au niveau des
départements et vous l'avait bien dit il
peut y avoir par rapport au patrimoine
routier départemental des cohérences des
morceaux de route à reprendre par contre
pour les régions ne comprend pas et dans
le texte la qui passe cette semaine
climat on traite d'écotaxe et d'une
écotaxe façon puzzle au niveau des
régions franchement on comprend pas bien
plus vous avez peut-être insuffisamment
répondu le ministre à philippe tabarot
sur la question des financements
relatives au cpe ère pour les petites
lignes ferroviaires ou là le ferroviaire
on est vraiment sur le temps long et
donc démarré avec des contrats de
projets état région qui ont
une visibilité limitée c'est un suffit
merci avant de donner la parole à madame
demain je voudrais rappeler à la
ministre
frédéric marchand avait posé une
question c'est au sujet de la cotation
des demandes de logement social à
l'échéance de 2021 en 2023 madame demain
oui il est en visio parce que j'ai c'est
le ministère du logement je n'ai pas la
réponse immédiate je lui donnerai merci
merci madame demain merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre moi j'aurai
deux petites questions qui intéressent
la simplification de l'action publique
locale
effectivement la dispersion des aides
aujourd'hui entre les appels à projets
du plan de relance se de l'ademe des
régions de l'europe ou encore des
intercommunalités font qu'en fait les
petites communes qui en ont le plus
besoin ayant le moins accès et je me
demandais pour rebondir sur ce sujet
déjà évoquée par mes collègues
si la loi cadre des allées abondé dans
une simplification pour pouvoir avoir
accès à ces des lacets z et peut-être si
elle prévoyait au en fin de compte un
guichet unique qui pourrait être
j'allais dire le moyen de pouvoir pour
ces petites communes à avoir accès à
tout ce panel dead
ça c'était la première question la
seconde intéresse
le fait de faciliter le partage de
données entre les administrations
c'est donc un d une des priorités de
cette loi afin d'éviter par exemple que
les usagers ne redonne plusieurs fois
les mêmes information administration
je voulais savoir selon vous quels
seront les principaux acteurs et moyens
à mobiliser pour apporter le soutien le
plus efficace à nos collectivités
pour atteindre cet objectif comment
envisagez-vous le rapprochement entre
les collectivités et l'état
pour ce faire comment donc doit-on
appréhender ce sujet merci merci
monsieur 20 tech
oui un bonjour madame la ministre en a
donc bien compris que le dic baja coma
girondins étaient étaient passés demande
d'ailleurs s'il faudrait pas commettre
dans la loi l'interdiction de corse
étages de type cahors c'est peuvent
ville de cahors ne vais rien demandé
pour être devenu le symbole finalement
la mainmise de l'état sur les finances
des collectivités au togo le recadrage
mais il y a quelques mois vous avez posé
une question dans l'hémicycle 1 suite à
la pétition qu'accambray glissant 5000
signatures en faveur d'un référendum sur
le redécoupage de la bretagne de la
loire atlantique et vous m'avez répondu
à l'époque avec la loi telle qu'elle est
on ne peut rien faire il faut donc
intervenir par la loi
c'est le moment depuis la quasi-totalité
des collectivités territoriales de loire
atlantique ont voté des délibérations en
faveur de cette consultation le
département les trois principales
communes c'est un consensus politique
puisque même candidate de droite pour la
région bretagne annonce qu'elle réunit
efira la bretagne on sait pas très bien
comment mais en tout cas elle annonce
qu'elle va le faire
donc madame la ministre est ce que vous
voyez de manière tout à fait
consensuelle
comment nous pouvons enfin avoir un
dispositif opérationnel qui permettent
des redécoupages et ça ne concerne pas
que la loire atlantique puisqu'on sait
très bien que la loi telle qu'elle est
faite aujourd'hui est fait pour que rien
ne bouge jamais donc je suis à votre
disposition qu'on me trouve un
dispositif qui respecte la démocratie tu
mens délit
oui je voudrais intervenir immédiatement
après les propos de mon collègue rené en
attaque pour lui rappeler que un
référendum une consultation n'a jamais
fait une décision politique et je lui
rappellerai sans détour le résultat du
référendum de la consultation sur les
reports note nantes atlantique et j'ai
dû appuyer sur un bouton
je pense que j'ai appuyé sur un bouton
là sur le bon bouton semble-t-il
monsieur de nicolay oui merci
c'est dans ce milieu tout juste un petit
bourg madame la ministre parce qu'on
s'aperçoit après le les discussions
qu'on a eues ce master nuque autant les
comités locaux des deux terres des s'il
fonctionne autant les comités locaux sur
l'agent spécial que l'on était et war
qui devraient coordonner l'ensemble des
politiques publiques sur un territoire
ne fonctionne pas et je pense qu'il ya
un vrai travail est un vrai travail de
la part de de cette agence pour faire en
sorte bien que on trouve deux à la fois
la simplification peut-être son
fonctionnement local et surtout surtout
de la cohésion et de l'information
auprès des élus locaux
et puis je me pose juste une question
sur le le cas de décès le des
différenciations parce qu'on le sent pas
bien sur l'ensemble de l'ensemble du
texte de loi
merci monsieur p nk zec et puis après la
ministre mais j'ai elle va avoir deux
minutes pour répondre à tous merci
monsieur le président
moi je voulais juste exprimer ma
déception parce que ça fait longtemps
qu'on attend ce texte est je trouve
qu'ils aient pas grand chose dedans si
ce n'est des soucis supplémentaires pour
les communes je vois le renforcement des
du contrôle des sociétés publiques
locales des espèces qu'est ce qu'elles
ont fait mon dieu on des mesures gadgets
on va nous permettre de fixer le nombre
d'élus des conseils ministration ça
relève du gadget et 3 des pétitions que
les gens vont pouvoir réaliser avec 10%
des électeurs ou 20% des opci
on n'a pas fini d'être emmerder quoi
plus que l'on connaît déjà quoi merci
dernière question monsieur layec
mais il ya quand même un petit truc sur
lequel j'aurai revenir là c'est sûr
l'ademe parce que vous me parlez
monsieur bigot
on parlait de 2 comment de jacobinisme
et de recentralisation
non mais attendez d'une manière générale
il ya un truc quand même que je voudrais
rappeler c'est que l'ademe c'est un
établissement public de l'état
je ne vois pas où est le problème
moi ce qui me gêne je vais vous dire
c'est quand je vais quelque part et que
je vois un directeur d'adem expliqué
qu'il est d'accord avec l'état ou qui
signent une convention avec l'état et
une collectivité territoriale
un accord tripartite ça ça me gêne
beaucoup parce que nous sommes dans un
établissement public de l'état et que le
préfet soit là je veux dire c'est pas
non plus je rappelle que pour la mct le
représentant de la société dans les
départements c'est le préfet que le
représentant de l'anah dans les
départements c'est le préfet que les
représentants de l'anru dans le
département
c'est le préfet et ça n'a jamais posé de
problème à personne
et si on met le préfet dans un rôle de
coordination au niveau de l'ademe
c'est pour faciliter les relations
notamment aussi avec les préfets de
département et c'est une demande qui
fait suite ce qu'on nous explique
toujours que la multiplication des
agences rend moins lisible l'action de
l'état donc on le fait pas pour mettre
la main sur
sur les décisions qui sont prises et qui
fonctionne effectivement dans les
départs dans les régions avec la
présence des élus mais je pense que là
il ya un truc on n'est pas l'ademe ça
n'est pas enfin je veux dire c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est qui dépend de
l'état
alors je sais pour aller au fond dans
votre sens que le premier ministre
edouard philippe a exigé que les
établissements publics de l'état remette
la marianne et remettent si vous voulez
sur les papiers sur lesquels il écrivait
république française parce que parfois
les agences étaient devenus très
autonome si je puis dire
très autonome donc il ya un moment c'est
des financements d'état monsieur aussi
vous comprenez j'essaie d'expliquer les
les choses et donc je veux dire quand on
nous demande monsieur je fais revenir
sur des sujets sur lequel vous n'êtes
pas allés jusque là aujourd'hui mais
quand tout le monde demande que le
préfet l'autorité sur la rs c'est
exactement la même démarche parce qu'il
ya des gens qui nous le demandent
donc il faut aussi que les choses soient
soient claires sur les francs service il
ya aussi des fonds d'investissement pour
aider les français revit sa à ceux à
s'installer un nous avons de la d2 terne
la décide de la dpv et des dotations de
relance je reviens sur les routes c'est
une expérimentation de la
régionalisation des routes et cette
expérimentation se fait sur une base
volontaire et si ça marche pas ben on
n'ira pas plus loin
mais quand on dit que la différenciation
n'est pas assez visible
je pourrais dire que les
expérimentations sur les routes sur les
instants sur les airs et ça c'est de la
différenciation
2 du pouvoir réglementaire dont on n'a
pas parlé pour les collectivités
territoriales c'est de la réponse de la
différenciation le renforcement des
travaux dans la cité apc de la
différenciation les décentralisations
pour les routes départementales à la
carte c'est de la différenciation je ne
reviens pas sur vivre la bretagne et
vivre les bretons il ya encore eu une
question hier d'actualité au sénat posée
par ton copain breton molac l'initiative
appartient aux collectivités
territoriales ah non c'est celle inverse
de ta réponse de la dernière fois que tu
nous as dit dans l'hémicycle la dernière
fois que pour arriver à débloquer le
dossier il fallait changer la loi donc
ma question c'est ce que les catalans
l'état aujourd'hui n'a pas les moyens de
faire une consultation formés d'accord
donc est ce que l'état est prêt à ce
qu'on change de la loi voilà un autre
sujet mais si moi c'est ma question bas
c'est la question de la loi cadre des
communs c'est quand la question de la
loi cadre des mairies à l'est précise la
question dont la réponse est non mais je
suis pas sûr que la loire atlantique
soit tout à fait d'accord j'étais prêt
mais ça c'est la consultation qui dira
mais l'état est il prêt à changer la loi
[Musique]
bien malin à nice merci merci et puis
alors bientôt dans l'hémicycle pour
parler de ce cette loi cadre des mercis
mainmise
[Musique]